did you know that san francisco has a
poo patrol
oh what a what now what no they have a
food department
what do they do well okay so like you
know the fire department does right
mm-hmm like this there's a fire you call
the fire department they come out put
the fire out san francisco has a poo
department
same thing
i don't think they actually have sirens
or anything but they should like the
people that pick up roadkill
it's job creation there's there you go
oh great
there's so much human feces all over the
streets of san francisco they had to
create a department they need to hit it
with lasers dude and turn it into
graphene
it's carbon-based talk about evil over
here
but just think about desalination
desalination which they have they have
one plant in carlsbad i think i've been
there it was really cool to watch
it they just massive tubes and they just
force at really high pressure the water
through these filters which then
purifies it and then pump out all the
brackish water back into the ocean
local environment environment
environmentalists are saying
the the the brackish water or it's brine
is it goes down to the bottom and kills
all of the base level organisms which
wipes at the food chain straight up i'm
sure it does
so then we have to pick which is a very
uh
major dilemma for people who are very
far left and progressive what matters
more human life or ocean life
and then we have to also pick on our
energy which uh everyone hates what
matters more turning off our power and
having rolling blackouts and all that or
providing drinking water if you took
away
luxury and security from the united
states you would have no leftists
[Laughter]
so i've said this for a really long time
and i gathered this by watching tock not
to the extent that you do marry
thankfully thank god i got banned i
don't know i know you did yeah you can't
watch anymore no i'm just kidding
they're stealing our information but i
figured that if we got rid of free time
we'd be good we'd be fine no more free
time none of these teachers with blue
hair talking about their weird genders
and confusing people with pronouns all
of that would be gone would just be
focused on our work it would be fine
that's my two cents that's like the
simplest thing
because
you'd have to erase 100 years of
technological advancement anywhere near
that and free time existed in a long
time ago we had tons of free time it's
just that it's the level of
communication and the level of of hyper
tribalization that's causing the
here's what i'm saying with with uh
you get rid of luxury and security you
have no leftists because when people
have to think about survival
that's when they're like me and no one
else and i'll do what it takes so you're
mentioning environmentalism yeah they're
gonna decide humans and they're gonna
decide themselves i hope so
you you're not gonna have
i mean
you may have people at this point who
are like starving and on the street
crawling being like i will not eat the
food i really doubt it they're gonna be
like i will eat you
and then i'll kick your door in and
they'll take your beans you know
you're you young me park said starvation
is like all you can think of is food
when you're cooking when you're starving
she came from north korea and fled the
country and said that she fled because
she was starving so she chose to go
become a sex slave in china to get out
so she had food right yeah she said that
she was like sitting there looking at
the lights and just thinking like i
wonder if there's food there people
grasshoppers like laying on the side of
the ground that have died from
starvation cannibalism i mean it's just
total total rampage yeah i think that a
lot of what we see in modern politics
particularly with feminism is due to the
fact that we are a bubble of security
yeah so if you think about evolutionary
psychology and you go bay you go way
back in time
like men were like we have to die to
protect the women because the women are
the ones who like create people yes so
you know men would if you if you have
100 men and 100 women and 99 men die
you your society survives because the
women can have kids but if 99 women die
you're done one woman could not sustain
a population boy that's some interesting
implications in that well yeah
it's it's the root it's the root of a
lot of uh um the gender roles if you
look at it it's look i'm not making this
up this is just like academic gender uh
evolutionary psychology
and so what happens is
gender roles emerged from that you take
a bunch of nomadic humans and they would
fortify the women because those that
didn't ceased to exist right and those
that did
thrived the men would go out and hunt
big game and bring back bring back fish
or protein the women would would you
know gather and keep food and and and
protect the family and keep the home
keep the home literally and then a bunch
of the guys would die on the hunt or in
war yep but the women would survive and
have kids so that and ends up with you
know in europe with the escalation of
warfare between nations the women are
staying in the home to be protected and
the men are going out and doing work and
then you build a society based on those
ideas and you get traditional gender
roles so i'm not saying those are good
things i'm just saying that's that's the
the common uh
human reality of our biological
conditions yeah
so we end up with this safety bubble and
luxury bubble we produce all this oil
and energy and now we have people who
can
gorge themselves and not have to do any
work i mean come on let's be real
the people in new york city who work at
like buzzfeed i always bring this up
millennials oh come on washington post
this this woman who gets fired because
she's complaining about dave weigel you
know making a sexist tweet
that could not exist
200 years ago seriously i mean maybe
some of those ideas started to exist
because we had technological
advancements
but if you're like we are being
bombarded in a raiding party just stole
the last of our chickens you wouldn't be
going like you said a naughty word you'd
be like i'm dying and i need food yeah
it's it's
it is first world problems right take
away the first world all that stuff goes
away i'm not saying it's a good thing
i'm just saying i don't think the modern
left could exist
in
i i kind of feel like if you took your
modern leftists
forced them to work on a farm yeah for a
couple weeks they would really change
their minds yeah unless they're like
deeply rooted in their
neuroses and then they would be like i
should be in charge of the farm and you
should serve me i mean that's kind of
what parents do with bad kids when they
send them off to wilderness survival
camp you know some of them come back
totally changed but even that is so
contrived and fake like i've been
thinking about it recently how like when
people grew up on farms and they saw
animals reproducing and giving birth and
dying
uh it would be impossible to have the
level of confusion about
gender and life and death that we have
right now
right if you were watching that as a
child as you grew up
you would be immune to the propaganda
that we're getting inundated with today
mccoy was on the show saying that exact
thing
he was raised around farm animals and
had no i mean just knew from age four he
never had the birds and the bees talk he
never had to because he always knew how
sex worked was it what sheamus i think
you mentioned someone asked him how did
people
learn how to reproduce before sex ed or
something like that was it james
somebody mentioned they had a friend who
was like how did we know about this by
watching animals what no not watching
animals like all of human existence yes
like i like that thing i'm going to that
person i just rewatched blue lagoon
recently
am i cancelled now because that was yes
we'll yeah we'll i won't even say why i
would be canceled for that but uh they
figured it out they figured it out and
they had a baby two people stranded on
an island uh since they were children
it's like it's almost like they're
innate biological drives yes
and that like a dude looks at a woman
goes i would like to you know grab that
woman yeah yeah
yeah yep
that's exactly it as the cartoons
dictate like how much free will do we
have as a species cause like you're
saying or you guys this keeps coming up
that like unless we're absolutely forced
to change like you're saying in
california if the power goes out then
you'll start to see people like pushing
this technology if they run out of water
they're going to start desalinating how
much of this is free will like how much
are we actually in control or like
deciding to go against our instinct how
much of it is just it's only when we
need to do it or we're going to do it
well it it's it's free will but there's
a lot of people who don't exercise free
will there's long-term thinking and
short-term thinking and i think
you'll find among the
i guess culture war right whatever you
want to call it i always just say post
liberals moderates libertarians and
conservatives a tendency towards
long-term thinking and delayed
gratification yeah and among the left
you get instant gratification and
short-term thinking high time preference
i'll give you a really good example
short-term thinking i'm seeing all of
these memes pop up it's crazy i don't
know why this meme is emergent on the
left and they're like why don't we plant
fruit trees in cities so that everyone
can just eat fruit and have to worry
about where their food comes from why
don't we just do the good things so that
the bad thing don't happen yeah do you
guys know why we don't do uh public
fruit trees in big cities so well
there's a couple of reasons you'll
probably have more one is the
contaminants from the air actually make
the the plants poisonous too is it takes
uh sometimes toxic yeah four four to
seven years to for a tree to bear fruit
that's true and then the other thing is
when we when we transplant fruit bearing
trees into cities the fruit rots and
then you get pests insects rats and
pigeons and then disease someone has to
come and collect the fruit and be and
maintain the truth yeah very very
beautiful it's it's this remarkably
childish short-term single-layer thought
yeah that i keep seeing where they're
like imagine walking down the street and
the trees had fruit on them it's like oh
and there's no negative repercussions
nothing else happens no one's got to
care for them no one maintains them the
fruit is just there and it stays there
until you're ready to eat it that is
this that is the talk of someone who's
never had a garden in their life you
know why we we grew tomatoes you know
what we did wrong we planted them all at
the same time
and you know what happens when you plant
all your tomatoes at the same time
they all ripen at the exact moment and
then it's like who wants to eat 300
tomatoes today yeah because they go bad
tomorrow and so then someone was like
tim you need to plant them one week at a
time plant one a week later plant one
then you'll get seven the next week you
get seven and i'm like oh yeah
yeah i didn't know that but the insects
will swarm and eat them if you don't
yeah so we we throw in the chickens we
just started like there you go chickens
and then here's the best part the
chickens poop out the seeds and they
grow again oh nice circle of life yeah
yeah because the the they'd poop
wherever and then also we know tomato
plants were growing and we're like oh
look at that all right well that's kind
of charming it worked out well that's
that's how it's supposed to go i mean
but you you you look at the single-layer
uh short-term thinking and that's
exactly what we've got more houses than
homeless people
what's wrong with this society we should
just put homeless people in houses and
i'm like
who's going to maintain the house who's
going to inspect the house who's going
to check the electrical wiring of the
house who is going to be paying
attention to any of the rot or termites
or any other problems in the houses
yeah you can't just put a homeless
person in a house but they don't they
don't these these utopian thinkers
typically leftists don't think beyond
that well the prosperity we have
now that we're living off of came from
the age of reason
and
that is why i think leisure time is
valuable and is necessary for human
flourishing but then now we're
sinking into the age of the will and
anything is true if we will it
well i think that has a lot to do with
with the lack of god and i don't mean
like from an overt religious perspective
i mean it from a
people who don't believe that things
exist beyond them or
or greater than them
so the people i feel like
there's a tendency among people who
believe i am nothing but a wet robot
nothing matters
to engage in more nihilistic thinking
like whatever feels good i'm going to do
yeah but people don't want to believe
that is to write a blank check for your
bad behavior
it's i wouldn't necessarily say bad
behavior because that implies that
they're like a morality i think it's
self aggrandizing and selfish behavior
carnal behavior okay
i see i see laziness and and apathy and
cowardliness also come out of that yeah
and that i think is
is really disappointing thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there